is it by design that essentially the
same amount of time has gone by between
the first and second and the second the
third nine years or is that just a
coincidence a couple years ago we
thought we'd be shooting this summer and
then some schedules moved around and it
we said okay we can do it it happened to
be nine years yeah that was a little
extra little bonus the first would be
the exact same amount of time so it kind
of incentivized this to jump into
production a little sooner there's
absolutely no rhyme and reason to the
first yeah it was nine years it was
really random that way as the
anniversary approached it seemed we used
it as motivation to do it we didn't do
it now I was worried we would never do
it we're a bit superstitious yeah i'll i
read the Entertainment Weekly interview
where you said that you want to keep
doing them until you guys are like
basically the couple from we were yeah
but we do it as a big comedy that's our
ongoing we're gonna do a comedic remake
yeah yeah all they do is like sit around
and watch movies of older people watch
George Burns films or something it was
important to see him with others I think
you say a lot about yourself and your
how you feel about others you know your
relationship kind of around others it's
you and you're different around others
like you can make you can you can
actually kind of like have a little
passive-aggressive
comment that no one else think you're
insulated you can get away with you know
you can like do all sorts of like
passive-aggressive you know I think the
biggest part was probably the the older
writer who had was hosting you guys you
know we thought well do we get it we
thought it would kind of puncture the
bubble a little bit we got someone
famous like if you knew him and we
talked about a lot of older actors you
know people in their 80s who were still
bringing it you know British yeah so it
was a little narrow but we ended up not
we ended up going with a guy an 85 year
old the older man there has never acted
he's a director of photography who won
the Oscar in 1963 for Zorba the Greek
he's this British guy who kind of went
to Crete and sort of never left you
he fell in love with me he had a long
career but so he had this Greek British
thing which was perfect for what we were
looking for and he kind of the way he
you know Walter the way kind of held him
you know carried himself like I'm an
Oscar winner the way he kind of wanted
thought he really should be the director
of photography on nothing on the movie
and the older woman was is kind of this
magnificent Greek actress who's one of
the biggest stars in Greece she owns her
own runs her own theater for children
and she's highly revered and I know
nobody could believe we got her to do it
but she loved that speech so much and he
came out of retirement yeah she's kind
of like the Audrey Hepburn or something
she's beloved and so well-known but
hasn't acted in over 30 years they all
thought they were gonna be this great
time improvising with Richard Linklater
they had seen them and they thought oh
this is gonna be so fun we're gonna hang
out and then Rick is the truth is that
Rick is merciless about rehearsal and
about and there's not a word improvise
them they were very in there they found
themselves weak sitting at them table
for weeks they were dripping with sweat
we're doing it again particularly Walter
you know I would have had this wrapped
two weeks ago on Zorba Zorba we would
have shot this in a master and moved on
yeah that was they were all it's like
three weeks of rehearsal I mean
everything is very scripted and very
rehearsed and very because rich always
tries to get everything in you know like
he loves those long takes and stuff and
it's true from the outside it seems so
naturalistic I mean that's kind of the
goal and improvise and stuff but those
people how little did they know when
they got said that it was gonna be
rehearsal and rehearsal and rehearsal
until I mean I think it's always our
goal is to make sure it's neither you
know just a man point of view or just a
woman's point of view or you know we're
very careful I mean to the line I would
say you know I think one line too many
from me or him could could could throw
things we really work on it like we
would work on you know sewing like very
fine lace it's like everywhere
every line is important and every even
even the other characters and stuff what
they say and stuff is important that it
doesn't become like some movie about you
know angry feminists you know because
that's not what Selene is you know and
neither the other way you know matches
them or whatever you know or even if
like even the fact of making these
movies were kind of initiating some idea
of a of a soulmate of some kind of soul
connection and it seems even important
inside the movie to try to debunk that
you know with to debunk it and then also
create the fact that well maybe it I
mean you know just didn't it's just a
constant point counterpoint I mean that
was the overarching subject this time
was romance at 41 what is it you know
especially what chase was that because
we've been considered to make two
romantic films so you know that was the
question what is romance how does it
change so it's something we all put a
lot of thought into over the years